Let me begin the lecture with
the keywords for the lecture.
Just a couple of words
that will help you
understand important themes
for this lecture and for
Wednesday, for the
entire week, really.
And those phrases are,
the keywords are
the Talented Tenth,
Talented Tenth,
uplift and respectability,
putting them together,
and race management.
Talented Tenth, uplift
and respectability,
and race management. Let
me start with a quote.
"It seems manifest
to me that as
a race in this land,
we have no art;
we have no science;
we have no philosophy;
we have no scholarship.
Individuals we have in each
of these lines, but mere
individuality cannot be
recognized as the
aggregation of a family,
a nation, or a race, or as
the interpretation of any of
them. And until we attain
the role of civilization,
we cannot stand up and hold
our place in the world of
culture and enlightenment.
And the forfeiture of
such a place means
inferiority, repulsion,
drudgery, poverty,
and ultimate death."
The quote is from a man
named Alexander Crummell,
from one of his final
publications--essays--called
"Civilization: The
Primal Need of a Race,
excuse me, "Civilization:
The Primal Need of the
Race." You'll see
in this lecture,
and perhaps even identified
a tiny bit in this quote,
some linkages to
the last lecture,
thinking about manliness and
civilization, and Ida B.
Wells Barnett, and the kinds
of claims she was making
about the white South, that
they were lacking in both.
Today we're talking--the
reason there's a linkage
there, we're talking about the
same era, generally speaking.
This week, we're going to move
from essentially the 1880s into
the first decade of the
1900s, just to give
you a chronological bearing.
And that overlaps a lot
with the lecture I was,
I had on Wednesday,
dealing with Ida B.
Wells' anti-lynching
crusades as well. Now I
started the lecture
with Alexander Crummell,
and let me explain why.
I think he's a nice
vehicle through which we can
understand a lot of the
themes of this week's
lectures. Crummell was a
black man, born into a free
family in 1819. His family
was essentially a minority
within a minority. Both
parents were literate, they
were active abolitionists,
and they enjoyed a
materially comfortable life
in that particular context.
Crummell is born free to
literate parents and active
abolitionists. He's not the
typical--this is not the
typical African American
experience prior to
emancipation. He's educated
by his father and at private
schools throughout the
Northeast, although not
without controversy. In one
of the schools he
came to in New York,
when the townspeople learned
that they were going to
educate free
blacks at that school,
really just a
one room house,
they hitched oxen to the
house and pulled it in to a
swamp. Anyway, Crummell
does get an education,
becomes a minister, and
then heads off to Cambridge
University in
1848, excuse me,
1845. Crummell's departure
for England and his
subsequent classical
training marked a watershed
moment in his personal
intellectual development.
He originally left the US
only to obtain a degree from
Cambridge and raise money to
build a new church back in
the United States. Now he
leaves in 1845. He does not
come back to the US, except
for two very brief visits,
he does not come back to
the US until 1872. So he is
gone from the country during
the great sectional crisis.
Goes to England in 1845, he
doesn't stay in England the
whole time. He starts
getting sick in England,
and then he decides to move
to a warmer climate for his
health. This is the
thinking of the time. He
departs for Liberia,
the West Coast of Africa,
in 1853, and he would
remain there for almost two
decades. By this action, it
appears as if Crummell was
doing exactly that which he
fought so strongly against
in his public orations prior
to this moment. He was
immigrating to Africa, just
as the African Colonization
Society recommended African
Americans do. This is a
group I mentioned in passing
a week and a half ago,
it's a, you know, a group
advocating blacks get out of
the United States, and
advocating colonization,
go back to where they
belong is the thinking,
in shorthand. Well, when
Crummell goes to England,
he goes there somewhat
against the activity of the
African Colonization
Society. He's campaigning
actively against that idea.
We should not send blacks,
you know, quote,
"back to Africa,
black Americans, that is.
Their homeland is the United
States. But by the time
Crummell leaves for Liberia,
he actually is advocating
colonization. So Crummell
goes through this
interesting shift,
it seems. He leaves
for England for a,
an advanced degree, and to
get the education and raise
funds to build a church back
in the United States. He
stays in England,
then leaves for Africa,
advocating colonization, the
very thing that he had been
fighting against for
his adult life up to that
point. Now Crummell's
advocacy for colonization is
different from that of
people like in the African
Colonization
Society who are saying,
"Let's just get this problem
out of our hair." Crummell
believed in the hierarchy
of civilization. That's an
important phrase, the
hierarchy of civilization.
And he believed
that African natives,
who in Crummell's
mind were pagan,
that African natives
were at the bottom of this
hierarchy. So instead of
advocating for blacks to
move to--black Americans to
move to Africa to solve an
American problem, he's
calling for black Americans
to move to Africa to solve
an African problem and a
Christian problem. Crummell
believed that at one time,
black Africans were at the
top of the civilizational
ladder, top of the
hierarchy. But over time,
with technical innovation
and divine providence,
very important, he
believed that Europeans,
especially the English,
were now at the top of the
hierarchy, top of this
ladder. So Crummell's
advocating blacks
come--black Americans come
to Africa to
save the Africans,
to Christianize
them, to rise them up,
to lift them up beyond their
pagan roots. Eventually,
Crummell becomes frustrated
in Liberia with his attempts
to civilize the
natives through letters in
educational salvation.
Returns to the United States
to head up one of the most
prominent
churches in Washington,
D.C., St. Luke's Episcopal,
serving a predominantly
black and almost exclusively
wealthy black community.
Comes back in 1872, starts
up this--heads up this
church and really helps
expand it and grow it,
and he dies in 1898. Now
what does all this have to
do with today's lecture?
Crummell embodies many of
the important elements that
define black leadership and
elite life in the second
half of the nineteenth
century. Although he
did not coin the phrase,
Crummell lived the ideology
that suggested the Talented
Tenth. The Talented Tenth
would be the ones to save
the race. Although he did
not live long enough to see
it mature, Crummell founded
the American Negro Academy.
More about that in a few
minutes. Crummell founded
the American Negro Academy
which took as its--as its
explicit mission to save the
race via the profound ideas
of the Talented Tenth.
And although Crummell sees
himself certainly as
at least a political
progressive, if
not a radical,
one can see in
this quick glimpse,
this tour of his biography,
a notion that blacks had not
attained sufficient
greatness to be considered
contributors to the
civilized world. You can
see in this kind of
ideology--this kind of
sentiment an inherent
conservatism. And in this
way, Crummell's a race
manager. So much of his
project is about trying to
find a way to save the race,
to manage its problems
and its solutions. Again,
the keywords for
today are Talented Tenth,
uplift and
respectability, and,
implicit in both, race
management. As I stated a
few minutes ago, this
lecture--this week's worth
of lectures lingers between
around 1890 and 1910,
an era famously referred
to, at least famously in the
black
community, as the nadir,
the worst part,
the N-A-D-I-R,
the nadir, the worst part of
the free black experience.
Saw last week frightful
representations of white
control via lynching, and I
talked about other methods
of social and political
control used by whites to
eliminate black economic
opportunity and the black
male voting presence.
Now as bad as
these things were,
there's no doubt
it was horrific,
it would be a mistake to
say that blacks were without
hope, that they were an
utterly downtrodden people,
doomed to their degraded
position. There were in
fact glimmers of
hope and activism,
even though it grew out
of a reality of despair.
So a profoundly
difficult time for the
post-emancipation
African American experience,
but don't bottle it up and
say it's all despair and all
misery. See, glimmers of
hope can be identified in,
sort of in essentially two
ways: on the ground in daily
acts of resistance, like the
kinds you had read about in
Tera Hunter's wonderful book
To 'Joy My Freedom. And you
see glimmers of hope
perhaps in polite society,
via the work of
reformers, churches,
societies, and
associations. A few quick
words about on the ground
resistance. We know from
Tera Hunter that thinking
about struggle--her book,
her argument, is about
struggle on the ground,
and the ways in which
the black community was
negotiating class politics
during this era--on the
ground struggles of daily
resistance means small acts
of resistance, until people
like Tera Hunter came along,
lost to history, one would
think. It's about doing
work more slowly than you
possibly can. It means
stealing scraps when you
know you shouldn't be,
stealing labor in a sense in
the houses where you work or
in the factories where you
worked. Quietly finding
ways to say no to the orders
that you've been given,
to the life you've
been forced to lead,
although outwardly you're
saying yes. You can't
discount these small acts of
daily resistance. They are
important. Think of Tera
Hunter's laundry workers who
would claim control of their
bodies in the evening when
they went out dancing.
They had some sort of real
psychological
relief, physical relief,
in exerting control over
their own bodies and being
out in a certain space,
even though their own--their
bosses wouldn't
have appreciated it,
and certainly the black
elite looked down their
noses at their
actions. This is important,
but it's also important to
realize the psychological
benefits could be fleeting,
in the acts of daily
resistance, because the
fact of the matter is,
when those workers woke up
the next morning after a
great night out, they
had to go back to work.
They had to find a way to
put food on the table. And
so although we cannot
discount the benefits of
psychological relief, we
need to understand them as
well for the real
limits that they had. Life
remained
difficult. Now you have,
at the same time as
Tera Hunter's washerwomen,
black activists who were
thinking of long-term gains
for the black community
that extended beyond the
boundaries of their own
body. These were the
people, it's
important to realize,
who had the freedom and
security to think beyond the
daily existence. They had
some means. Now we're not
talking wealthy
people, rich people,
but they had some sort of
security. They knew there
were meals
coming all week long.
Their--their house,
they owned their house,
they had shelter. They had
some measure of education.
So they had the leisure time
to think about long-term
solutions. These were
the people who considered
themselves the Talented
Tenth. These were the
people who thrived in polite
society and who saw it as
their duty to uplift
the race. Bless you.
This last phrase, I want you
to think about and what's
important for this lecture.
They saw it as their duty to
uplift the race. Now for
the rest of the lecture I'm
going to, in a sense,
explore that phrase,
and extrapolate meaning from
it. For the rest of the
lecture, I want to explore
uplift's roots in the
Northern church. I'll
explore the linkage between
uplift and the new growth
of associations in American
culture. But
most importantly,
I want to explore uplift's
investment in gender
dynamics and uplift's
equally subversive and
conservative nature. It's
really critical that you
understand uplift
was, at its core,
a dynamic ideology that
was imbued with that era's
restrictive gender and class
conventions. There's a
gendered element to uplift,
there's a class element to
uplift, that make uplift
both subversive--subversive
and conservative.
Think back to my framing of
Alexander Crummell's life.
He considered himself a
political progressive
and yet his ideology was
fundamentally conservative.
Let's look at uplift's
roots. We can trace uplift
back as an identifiable
ideology to a group called
the American Baptist Home
Mission Society, the
American Baptist Home
Mission Society. It's a
Northern and white-run
effort to educate and
civilize Southern blacks.
It's the post-Emancipation
and Reconstruction era we're
talking about here.
The American Baptist Home
Mission Society
is a Northern,
white-run effort to educate
and civilize Southern
blacks. One of the leaders
of the Home Mission Society
is a man named
Henry Morehouse.
He's the man, white man, who
coined the phrase Talented
Tenth, that that ten
percent of black America,
really much more like a
tenth of one percent,
would be that group
to uplift the race,
to lift it up. In
fact, Henry Morehouse,
for those who know
your historically black
colleges--colleges
and universities,
Morehouse College, the most
important black college for
educating black men
in history--still is,
still is there today, still
doing amazing work--is named
for Henry
Morehouse. Anyway,
this is an era when church
membership--so why the
American Baptist Home
Mission Society? This is an
era when church membership
is increasing rapidly,
but organized religious
bodies start to clash with
what can best be called
grassroots black worship
styles from religious
organizations. One of the
things that's important to
recognize is that much as
prior to emancipation,
blacks couldn't marry,
they couldn't
get an education,
very often they couldn't
practice their own religious
faiths, certainly not openly
and publicly. So you see a
sort of boom
within black America,
a public exhortation,
or demonstration,
of the desire to practice
faith. But they wanted to
do it in their own ways
and form their own religious
organizations. This is
a complicating factor,
to put it mildly, when it
came to the American Baptist
Home Mission Society. The
Home Mission Society was
coming down from the North,
setting up schools and
churches, setting up schools
in sort of the same spirit
as the Freedmen's
Bureau, setting up churches,
Baptist churches, setting
up an order of prayer,
systems of
practice, to educate and
civilize--civilize
through faith,
adherence to the Bible and
Christian ethics--so to save
the, save the race. Well,
blacks begin to bristle at
the fact that they are
not allowed by the American
Baptist Home Mission
Society structure,
that they aren't allowed
to contribute to the Sunday
school teaching literature.
Whatever they had to teach
on a Sunday was, quote,
"given to them" by this
Northern church. The
American Baptist Publication
Society refused their
contributions. It's a
tension here about religion
and religious teaching,
practices certainly, but
it's also about control over
their secular activities.
The American Baptist Home
Mission Society wanted
blacks to function in
accordance with their
guidelines and their
principles.
And, increasingly,
blacks were
saying, "I'm, you know,
I'm getting frustrated by
this." You have a breaking
point in 1895, the year, as
you'll see over this lecture
and next lecture, very
important year. Serious
breach appears in 1895
when a number of blacks come
together, Southern blacks,
too frustrated any longer to
abide by the American
Baptist Home Mission
Society's edicts, and
forms its own society,
the National Baptist
Convention. The National
Baptist Convention is
created by and about
blacks. It's organized to
establish black control over
the church, their churches,
their religious practices
and secular activities.
It even goes as far as to
establish its own publishing
company so it could produce,
among other things, Sunday
school literature written by
blacks. So you have
the American Baptist Home
Mission Society coming
down from the North with a
frankly patronizing attitude
about saving the race.
After some time,
the race says,
"We'll form our own
organization if you won't
let us have some control in
our own churches." Thus the
National Baptist Convention
is formed. Now before going
any further,
going any further,
it's important to think
about what a church actually
was. These were
places to worship,
of course, but it's also
important to realize that
churches play many
different roles in the black
community, and the
white community as well,
but we're talking about the
African American experience
right here. These churches
were places where they
taught literacy. Certainly
that's what Sunday school
classes are
partly about as well,
but we're talking sort of
daily education. They were
also places to find food.
If you're running short on
food, you go to the
church to be fed or get some
supplies--provide
basic healthcare,
employment information,
clothes. So the church was
not just a place
functioning in the black
community--community as a
site on Sundays to be in
deep reflection and other
days to seek solace. It was
doing that
certainly, but also feeding,
educating, clothing
the black community,
and providing basic
healthcare as well. So the
church needs to be
understood as what one
scholar calls "a discursive
space in the black public
sphere whose very conscious
role was to uplift the
race." "A discursive space
in the black public sphere
whose very conscious role
was to uplift the race."
Saving the race
through God, through food,
through education,
through clothing,
through healthcare, across
the board. So churches were
religious and secular
spaces. Now in addition to
the growing secular activity
of the black church,
there's a rapid
expansion of intellectual,
social, and literary
societies in black America.
Now this is a
phenomenon across the races,
the United States
during this time,
the late nineteenth
century. It's important to
realize the significant
organizations in black
America weren't--black
America weren't just the
churches. There's cultural
and intellectual societies
as well.
As far as black
America was concerned,
these societies,
these associations,
were all a part of
the struggle to become
self-sufficient. It's
important to protect its own
flanks and to provide
for those who are less
fortunate. So you have
fraternal orders and benefit
societies, like the
Masons, the Odd Fellows,
the Knights of Tabor,
all of which were for men.
Or the Order of
the Eastern Star,
the Sisters of the Calanth
for women. You have secret
societies offering
insurance--insurance against
sickness and death, and aid
to widows and orphans. And
then eventually, you
have insurance societies,
companies, most famously the
North Carolina Mutual Life
Insurance Company. This is
the largest black business
in the United States for
quite some time. The rise
of black banks and so
on. So you see a range of
really, for lack
of a better phrase,
community service
associations developing.
Places for fellowship, sort
of a secular fellowship,
certainly, but also a
place to gather to sort out
information about somebody
who might be in trouble that
we can help out, to sort
of raise funds to improve
schools by hiring a
new teacher perhaps;
to provide resources
when somebody dies,
a mutual aid
benefit society;
give resources
to the children,
widows; to literally put
your money someplace. These
were all rather dramatic
changes. They may not--may
not seem like
much, but again,
when you're
starting from zero,
anything is something. So
in addition to these service
societies, you have
intellectual societies,
like the
American Negro Academy,
founded in 1897. The ANA,
the American Negro Academy,
was not the
first of its sort,
but it was the first
to talk about uplift in
systematically intellectual
ways. So it's not about job
training.
It's not about
finding clothes or food for
somebody. It's about saving
the race through the power
of the intellect and through
training. The ANA was
limited to twenty or so
leading men of the race,
this would be the phrase of
the time. Women were not
allowed. And the
goal of the ANA,
those twenty leading men,
would be to develop the next
generation of leaders to
solve America's racial
ills. It's a
rather ambitious goal,
but that was it,
quite literally. W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, someone who--a
lot of you may see "Du-bwah"
when you see the
name, it's "Du-boys,
that's the way his
family pronounced it--W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, who we'll
hear more about tomorrow,
and we'll hear about
intermittently throughout
the course, a man of
incredible importance in the
twentieth century African
American experience--Du Bois
had just received his Ph.
D.
from Harvard, and is the
first vice president of the
organization.
He's Alexander Crummell's
protégé. As I said before,
the ANA was exclusive to
men. It's an organization
that really lasts about
twenty-five years before it
falls apart. I can't say
that it changes much of
anything.
It establishes a
journal, it publishes ideas,
it has lectures. Early
on, it allowed one woman to
lecture before its august
body. But that was sort of,
I mean I'm simplifying it,
but the ANA did not offer
much in transactional
change for black America,
but it's articulating a
vision that the way to save
the race was through
developing the intellect,
civilizing the race with its
most educated men. Right at
the same time the American
Negro Academy is formed,
in fact a year earlier,
another association is
formed, certainly more
important and effective,
called the National
Association of Colored
Women. The National
Women, NACW. Tellingly,
the motto of the NACW is
"Lifting while we climb."
Now what did it do? It was
sort of an amalgamation of
the American
Negro Academy ethos,
and the American Baptist
Home Mission Society,
and National Baptist
Convention. It's an
organization of
middle and upper classes,
as far as status--social
status--middle and upper
class black women, the "best
sort" as it were. That they
would gather together
on a, I don't know,
twice a month,
monthly basis,
network socially certainly.
But they would also organize
political protests,
something really quite
astonishing. This is
not the kind of person,
not the kind of woman, not
the kind of class figure who
would publicly protest. But
I didn't think to bring the
image with me, but in
the very first lecture,
I showed a slide of members
of the NACW picketing the
White House for an
anti-lynching law in the
1930s. Here's a woman who'd
walk the picket line to
press a political point.
And they also conducted
basic agitation for child
welfare reform. So they're
trying to network
amongst themselves,
raise the political stakes,
and also agitate for child
welfare reform.
They're like the ANA,
because they're a
certain type of person,
of class. They're like the
Baptist Home Mission Society
in the sense that they were
trying to uplift the race,
save the children. And in
a sense like the National
Baptist Convention, by
acting in explicitly
political ways. And
the National Baptist
Convention's own creation
was an explicitly political
act. Thinking from
the NACW's perspective,
uplift can be seen as
both subversive and
conservative. It
was subversive,
since it was helping educate
and clean up poor and
unclean people.
Sad, sad to say,
but this was a
subversive act,
trying to clean people
up, trying to improve their
health. And this is really
something you need to be
aware of. This was an
era of an epidemiologist's
nightmare. Cities are
really forming rapidly.
People are coming
to urban centers,
but hygiene isn't coming
as fast as the people are
coming. Cities and streets
literally built on top of
filth, of refuse,
excrement. Disease is in
the air. Tera Hunter
lays this out in her book,
all these campaigns to teach
proper hygiene habits. It
wasn't just about nice
manners--nice manners and a
white dress. These were
life and death kind of
skills they were trying
to teach the poor and the
unclean. Trying to wage
anti-tuberculosis campaigns,
for instance. So the NACW
is trying to do something
radical by trying to help
educate and clean up people
who were ignored by
society. But it was
also--excuse me, and it was
also subversive for the way
it engaged in explicit acts
of political resistance like
picketing,
advocating anti-lynching,
the passing of
anti-lynching law,
lobbying people. But uplift
from NACW's perspective,
or its--the way it
interpreted uplift,
was also quite conservative,
because NACW membership
recognized in itself the
express need for them to
clean up the race; that
the duty--I used the phrase,
the word earlier in the
lecture--it was the "duty"
of the black
middle and upper class,
especially the
women, to save the race,
to clean it up and to get
the poor and dirty blacks,
Southern blacks, to learn
how to behave respectably.
Think back to
the last lecture,
the manliness
and civilization,
respectability floating
through all of that. To the
women of the NACW, they
had a lot of work to do.
Most blacks were
unclean, and poorly behaved,
and uneducated. So uplift
taken all together then,
radical and conservative,
but essentially a
manifestation of white
middle class propriety that
these black
Victorians grew up in,
took it as their own, and
tried to perfect it for the
next generation. Black
women felt a sense of duty,
these black middle class
women and upper class women
felt a sense of duty, and
they had a special ability
from their self-conception.
They had a special ability
to save the race.
Anna Julia Cooper,
the leading black feminist
theorist of her day,
who was also a leading
educator having taught at
Dunbar High
School--actually,
I want to talk about Dunbar
for just a few seconds,
because it's actually a
remarkable institution.
I'll probably mention it
in a few weeks. Anna Julia
Cooper taught mathematics
at--It was actually the M
Street High School at
the time in Washington,
D.C. Its name is changed
eventually to Dunbar.
Dunbar becomes the
breeding ground,
over the first five decades
of the twentieth century,
of the black leadership
elite for the D.C.
area and, actually, for much
of the nation. If you look
at a lot of black
political leaders,
you will often see Dunbar
High School on the résumé.
So, you know, talking
about a leading intellectual
teaching at a high
school, and that,
and that, how can that be
important? Dunbar was not
your typical high school.
It was by far the best black
high school in the country.
It was the best public high
school in the District,
black or white. If you look
at the kind of training that
the teachers had and the
eventual career
path of its graduates,
it's an astonishing
institution. Anyway Anna
Julia Cooper, leading
theorist of her day,
teaches at Dunbar High
School. Later on in her
career, she leaves Dunbar.
I think she's sixty-three
when she gets her Ph.
D.
from the Sorbonne. She
comes back to Washington,
D.C., and
establishes a university,
Frelinghuysen University--I
probably butchered it,
I don't know German.
Essentially an evening
university, "university"
in sort of quotes,
an institution where black
workers who want to make
that next step in
advancement will come and
get training in the evening,
and so they can get a better
job. That's all quite a big
tangent. Anna Julia Cooper,
the leading black feminist
theorist of her day and
educator, exemplified this
uplift ideology espoused by
the NACW, and she made
all of this quite clear,
as early as 1892, even
before the NACW was formed.
There's a, There's an
interesting history behind
NACW, two different black
women's organizations trying
to fight it out over
which would be the one to
represent the race, and
they merged in the NACW. In
1892, years before
the NACW is formed,
years before the American
Negro Academy is formed,
Anna Julia Cooper
writes her manifesto,
A Voice from the
South. It's a long book,
very important.
We can reduce it,
at least today, to one
quote. Cooper says,
in A Voice from the South,
"Only the black woman can
say where and when I
enter, in the quiet,
undisputed dignity
of my womanhood,
without violence and without
suing or special patronage,
then and there the whole
Negro race enters with me."
"Only the black
woman," I repeat,
"Only the black woman can
say where and when I enter,
in the quiet, undisputed
dignity of my womanhood,
without violence and without
suing or special patronage,
then and there the whole
Negro race enters with me."
Women, black women,
black elite women,
black educated
women, were the ones,
the only ones,
who could say how,
when, and where blacks would
rise up and join society as
rightful members.
Now Alexander Crummell,
a man of his own time,
recognized Anna Julia
Cooper's intellect and
her, and her unique skills,
but he was certainly as
conservative on gender lines
as one might expect. He
certainly would have taken
issue, or took issue with
the idea that it was women
upon whom this
burden was placed,
to uplift the race. So
there's a sort of gendered
battle there about who it
was most prepared to save
the race.
But Cooper and Crummell
shared the same ideology.
It's the educated person,
the civilized person,
that's who would save the
race. Uplift is a middle
class ideology then that
was as much about race
management as it was about
anything else. Who was
going to manage the
race during a period of
transition?
Post-Reconstruction,
era of Redemption, an era
of the destruction of black
male voting rights. Cooper
declares that since women
were
perfectively respectable,
a certain kind of woman,
that they were the ones who
would be the
best race managers,
who could espouse a Talented
Tenth ideology and help
navigate the race to a
better way of living.
Respectability is something
that you really need to
linger on here, as well,
throughout all of this.
It's the reflection of
a bourgeois vision that
vacillates between an attack
on the failure of America to
live up to its liberal
ideals of equality and
justice. Think about Ida B.
Wells, that the white South
lacked a proper notion of
respectable behavior,
because it was lynching
these people. So
respectability could
vacillate between an attack
on the failure of America to
live up to its
liberal ideals,
like Ida B.
Wells did, or respectability
could be used as an attack
on the values of lifestyles
of the very blacks who
transgressed this white
middle class propriety. It
cuts both ways.
People like Ida B.
Wells could tell
white America,
"Shame on you for being so
cowardly when you brandished
the whip and threatened with
the lynching mob." Ida B.
Wells could also tell
black Americans she believed
beneath her--this
wasn't really Ida B.
Wells's style,
but I'm taking,
extending the point--"Shame
on you for acting in ways
that are improper." Now I
opened this lecture with
a quote from Alexander
Crummell about the need for
civilization, sketched out
Crummell's life experiences
and explained why he's
such a great representative
figure for the era. Let me
close with a quote from his
protégé, W.
E.
B.
Du Bois. This will be one
of the main figures I'll
focus on in--on Wednesday's
lecture. We can see in this
quote the way in which the
ideology of the Talented
Tenth was driven by
commitment to uplift the
race and that this
race was driven by the
belief that the black poor,
the black unwashed, were a
negative drain on all blacks
in America. Again, uplift
was race management. And by
the way, for those of you
who know a thing or two
about W.
E.
B.
Du Bois and the
phrase Talented Tenth,
these two are linked,
because Du Bois does write
about the Talented Tenth,
but he's not the person who
coins the phrase. He uses
it from Morehouse's American
Baptist Home
Mission Society,
just so you're straight
on this issue. Anyway,
Du Bois says the
following: "Men of America,
the problem is
plain before you.
Here is a race transplanted
through the criminal
foolishness of your fathers.
Whether you like it or
not the millions are here,
and here they will remain.
If you do not lift them
up, they will pull you down.
Education and work are the
levers to uplift a people.
Work alone will not do it
unless inspired by the right
ideals and guided
by intelligence.
Education must not
simply teach work,
it must teach Life.
The Talented Tenth of the
Negro race must be made
leaders of thought and
missionaries of culture
among their people.
No others can do this work,
and Negro colleges must
train
them--train men for it.
The Negro race,
like all other races,
is going to be saved by
its exceptional men."
Okay, I'll stop there, and
we'll begin on Wednesday
talking about--we'll focus
on Wednesday talking about
Du Bois and his
great foil, Booker T.
Washington, and all of
the different competing
ideologies that are
expressed in this time of
incredible change for
black America. Thank you.